bella tutti ragazzi e brevissimo video
sono fuori j
e oggi siamo su crismas shopper simulato
è un gioco di natale quindi sono
leggermente in ritardo da ragazzi fermi
un attimo dopo
io non so come ho fatto ancora non gioca
ma dovevo assolutamente qualche bello
che hai provato
facciamo una donna perché sono sexy
cosèta compiuto io ma answer the phone
risponde al telefono non c'è nessuna
reception prima puoi trovare ok
sono partito per caso qualche strana
ragione per cui la tizia diventa pelata
quando avvicino la telecamera non lo
voglio saperne va bene così the game is
home visit game store che bello sto
gioco di vento pelato a caso che sono il
caso rotto giuro che non volevano un
cazzo sto facendo disastro ma anche
perché che è successo lì è morto un
tizio caso
ragazzi ma con la sua gente in questo
gioco conta zio attenti serve una mano
zio questa successo ma perché la gente
con la stato a terra ascolta amico mio
ti portino ambulanza se riesco c'è una
buona ma perché era chiaro che io non lo
sto caffè ma cosa fa
[Applauso]
i toni voglio capire perché non ho
giocato a questa roba prima ok ho rotto
qualcosa da nintendo wii non la uil hawa
e bellissima è continua con lasciare la
gente
buongiorno amico mio che bello che sei
ascoltami posso comprare qualcosa tipo
dalla la bozza
ecco che compro questo tolta mio posto
cosa stai guardando to levati non piace
la mia gamba sexy di la verità c'è io
non ho capito come mai se non sono
svenuto io gioco dove viene la gente a
casa non ho capito perché ecco perfetta
di cristiano ronaldo si appresta al tiro
prende la carica al tiro
[Musica]
quanto a veloci muti non è chiaro andato
devo portare un morto
cosa stanno facendo le gambe
[Musica]
vi prego usciamo da quater che sconta no
non ci sono i saldi non corre a mi
chiami madonna la pazzia per i saldi
ragazzi troppo
cioè io vorrei capire un attimo ma
perché trascina le cose come un bastone
non voglio capirlo ok cell
ovvio ma c'è ma è normalissima però c'è
una renna che sani ma vaffan bene ha
tirato un calcio a un arena beccato di
tutti quanta roba secondo me rischiavo
di uccidere sta facendo sta tizia cioè
ragazzi quando si dice che la fila a noi
ama gesù ma è la fila al cesso questa
per andare al cesso
se non è questa se l'è fatta sotto
direttamente giuro che mi dispiace però
mica morite tu ecco ho fatto male scusa
io ho una palla quindi posso passare
avanti grazie grazie
mi scusi dal vivo german ma si stanno
facendo i cazzi loro questi c'è la gente
fuori che aspettano si fanno incazzarci
loro haka dovesse liberarlo al bagno
perché c'è gente che aspetta la bene
così facendo tutto ma ti sei sentito ma
che cosa è successo amico mio non volevo
darti fastidio scusa voglio capire
veramente il senso di questa cosa non
perché non me lo spiego con che la
latina posso berla di nuovo ecco bene
perfetto che posso fare oddio ragazzi e
bellissimo presepe ville a latina cori
come un deficiente scusate ma buongiorno
a lei sconti sto cercando un regalo per
non mi dispiace non volevo prendere dei
regali no questo è mio
ho detto che mio ho detto che è mio ok
grazie amico mio ma io tengo sempre
quello che voglio non c'è bisogno scaldi
vorrei comprare un po di questo se
possibile perfetto ragazzi arriva la
gran botta parla minchia che lorda gli
ho dato che non si vede niente o
impossibile del telefono che suona
pronto pronto pizza al con steve jobs
shampoo ma sempre la trova un po di
shampoo scritte proporta la nella grotta
e mando perché c'è un arena sul soffitto
anche se anche la freccia che dicevano
andare perfetto giorno c'è una posso
prendere dello shampoo ecco perfetto
grazie devo pagare questa cosa gb grazie
così si impacchetta meno legali
ragazzino aqua a lei mi spedisce le cose
grazie felici sta merda e poi ti rialzi
anche io sto veramente sto gioco lo devo
capire perché
giuro e non lo sto capendo caso successo
se è successo
stai facendo io capisco che l'amore tra
un essere umano è un cestino
c'è però ma con tieniti gesuele roba
bellissima l'avessi saputo prima aveva
ben possibile saltare non li saprà così
vero invece no si sono fatti fatemi
entrare qua dentro che voglio vedere
cosa
buongiorno ho messo la gamba in un
computer morso computer dio ragazzi
male molto male sono finito in mezzo al
pavimento perfetto è sono tornato a
posto
non l'ho scoperto prima non so per quale
il quale magia arcana però dovevo
scoprirlo cosa hai visto zio ha visto un
computer a io ti offro questa bellissima
stampante di nuova generazione non ti
piaceva la stampante verona è fini il
computer la stampa di tutto tutto in
omaggio molto ragazzi mi porto avanti un
attimo perché non è possibile
scusi ragazzi non so più veramente che
cosa descrive come descriverlo questo è
veramente assurdo perché stavolta giando
una palla di preciso che sembrava guai
della sod arrivano ti do della soda
gratis dai accetta questa solida da
parte mia è un regalo di nozze ma questo
è omicidio ma perché il giochino le
persone io vorrei capire chi è che mi
sta permettendo di fare questa cosa
oddio ragazze o mio dio e james bond
basta non ho mai pensato di utilizzare
nella mia vita una persona come rampino
ma c'è sempre una prima volta per tutto
ne detta est anche se tutti si stancano
dopo una giornata passata a fare
shopping vate l'importante è rialzarsi e
rimettersi piedi cosa vuoi domitia cosa
vuoi
polar express il tuo orso polare ha
bisogno di un jumper questo ero già
proprio dire che bello
posso prendere questa è una scusa ecco
per l'operaio tiro giù così le cose da
cazzo giorno vorrei comprare un jumper
se è possibile lo compri grazie già
impacchettato ma che bello lo prendo lo
prendo grazie mille pollo porto d'armi
orso polare che gli serve fantasia mi
spedì si sta merda poi ti rialzi sempre
propri ma spedisce bene ragazzi è
concluso un regalo sto regalo zio ecco
perfetto con ragazzi io concludo che
l'episodio fa male nel culo sta cosa
contuso più l'episodio spero che vi sia
piaciuto perché se un po in ritardo il
christmas simulator però si può fare i
ragazzi spero che a vino vi sia piaciuto
cosa se il vostro fido è piaciuto a
sottomento mi piace anche poggiani
facebook e come non divide tra l'altro
in descrizione sono se volessi discreti
ci dividiamo prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]